you wrote the essay why AI will save the
world
let's start the very high level what's
the main thesis of the essay yeah so the
main thesis on the essay is that what
we're dealing with here is intelligence
um and it's really important to kind of
talk about the sort of very nature of
what intelligence is and
fortunately we have a we have a
predecessor to machine intelligence
which is human intelligence and we've
got you know observations and theories
over thousands of years for what what
intelligence is in the hands of humans
and what intelligence is right I mean
what it literally is is the way to uh
you know capture process analyze
synthesize information solve problems
um but the observation of of
intelligence in human hands is that
intelligence quite literally makes
everything better
um and what I mean by that is every kind
of outcome of like human quality of life
whether it's education outcomes or
success of your children
for a Career Success or health or
lifetime satisfaction
um by the way um uh uh propensity to
peacefulness as opposed to violence uh
propensity for open-mindedness versus
bigotry those are all associated with
higher levels of intelligence smarter
people have better outcomes and almost
as you write you know every domain of
activity academic achievement job
performance occupational status income
creativity physical health longevity
learning new skills managing complex
tasks leadership entrepreneurial success
conflict resolution reading
comprehension financial decision making
understanding others perspectives
creative arts parenting outcomes and
life satisfaction one of the
more depressing conversations I've had
and I don't know why it's depressing I
have to really think through why it's
depressing but on IQ
and uh the G Factor
and that that's something in large part
is genetic
it correlates so much with all of these
things and success in life
it's like all the inspirational stuff we
read about like if you work hard and so
on
damn it sucks that you're born with the
hand that you can't change but what if
you could you're saying basically a
really important point I think it's a uh
in your articles
it really helped me
um
it's a nice added perspective to think
about listen human intelligence the
science of intelligence is shown
scientifically that it just makes life
easier and better
the smarter you are and now let's look
at artificial intelligence
and
if uh that's a way to increase the the
some human intelligence then it's only
going to make a better life yeah that's
the argument and certainly at the
collective level we could talk about the
collective effect of just having more
intelligence in the world which which
will have very big payoff but there's
also just at the individual level like
what if every person has a machine you
know and it's a concept of augment Doug
engelbert's concept of augmentation
um you know what if everybody has a an
assistant and the assistant is you know
140 IQ
um and you happen to be 110 IQ
um and you've got you know something
that basically is infinitely patient and
knows everything about you and is
pulling for you in every possible way
wants you to be successful and anytime
you find anything confusing or want to
learn anything or have trouble
understanding something or want to
figure out what to do in a situation
right I want to figure out how to
prepare for a job interview like any of
these things like it will help you do it
and it will therefore the combination
will effectively be you know well if you
effectively raise your raise because it
will effectively raise your IQ will
therefore raise the odds of successful
life outcomes in all these areas so
people below the this hypothetical 140
IQ it'll pull them up towards 140 IQ
yeah yeah and then of course you know
people add people at 140 IQ will be able
to have a peer right to be able to
communicate which is great and then
people above 140 IQ will have an
assistance if they can Farm things out
to and then look God willing you know at
some point these things go from future
versions go from 140 IQ equivalent to
150 to 160 to 180 right like Einstein
was the estimated to be on the order of
160.
um you know so when we get you know 160
AI like will be you know when one
assumes creating Einstein level
breakthroughs and physics and and then
and then at 180 we'll be you know curing
cancer and developing warp drive and
doing all kinds of stuff and so it is
quite possibly the case this is the most
important thing that's ever happened the
best things ever happen because
precisely because it's a lever on this
single fundamental factor of
intelligence which is the thing that
drives so much of everything else
can you still man the case that human
plus AI is not always better than human
for the individual you may have noticed
that there's a lot of smart
running around sure yes right and so
like it's smart there are certain people
where they get smarter you know they get
to be more arrogant right so you know
there's one huge flaw although to push
back on that it might be interesting
because when the intelligence is not all
coming from you but from assist from
another system that might actually
increase the the amount of humility even
in the one would hope
um or it could make more
you know that's I mean that's
that's for psychology to study yeah
exactly another one is um the smart
people are very convinced that they you
know have a more rational view of the
world and that they have a easier time
seeing through conspiracy theories and
hoaxes and right you know sort of crazy
beliefs and all that there's a theory in
Psychology which is actually smart
people so for sure people who aren't as
smart are very susceptible to hoaxes and
conspiracy theories but it may also be
the case that the smarter you get you
become susceptible in a different way uh
which is you become very good at
marshalling facts to fit preconceptions
right
um you become very very good at
assembling whatever theories and
Frameworks and pieces of data and graphs
and charts you need to validate whatever
crazy ideas got in your head and so
you're susceptible in a different way
right uh we're all sheep but
different colored some sheep are better
at justifying it right
um and those are the you know those are
the smart sheep right
um so yeah look like it I would say this
look like there are no fantasy I'm not
I'm not a utopian there are no panaceas
in life um there are no like you know I
don't believe they're like pure
positives I'm not a transcendental kind
of person like that but you know so yeah
there are going to be issues
um uh and um and you know look smart
people another thing maybe you could say
about smart people as they are more
likely to get themselves in situations
that are you know beyond their grasp you
know because they're just more confident
that their ability to deal with
complexity and their their eyes become
bigger their cognitive eyes become
bigger than their stomach you know so
yeah you could argue those eight
different ways nevertheless on that
right clearly overwhelmingly again if
you just extrapolate from what we know
about human intelligence you're
improving so many aspects of life if
you're upgrading intelligence
so there'll be assistance at all stages
of life so when you're younger there's
for Education all that kind of stuff or
mentorship all of this and uh later on
as you're doing work and you've
developed a skill and you're having a
profession you have an assistant that
helps you excel at that profession so at
all stages of Life yeah I mean look the
theory is augmentations this is the
gecko Birds term for either The Jungle
Book made this observation many many
decades ago that you know basically it's
like you can have this oppositional
frame of Technology where it's like us
versus the machines but what you really
do is you use technology to augment
human capabilities yeah and by the way
that's how actually the economy develops
that's we can talk about the economic
side of this but that's actually how the
economy grows is through technology
augmenting human human potential
um and so yeah and then you basically
have a proxy or a you know or or a a um
you know a sort of prosthetic um you
know so like you've got glasses you've
got a wristwatch you know you've got
shoes you know you've got these things
you've got a personal computer you've
got a word processor you've got
Mathematica you've got Google this is
the latest viewed through that lens the
AI is the latest in a long series of
basically augmentation methods uh to be
able to raise human capabilities it's
just this one is the most powerful one
of all because this is the one that goes
directly to but what they call fluid
intelligence which is IQ